Growing up in a small Virginia town near the
mountains, right on the border of West Virginia,
Zane heard all kinds of stories from his grandmother.
Tales of mountain lions who could transform
into ghostly women.
The tailypo, a fluffy rodent-like creature
on an endless quest to get its tail back from
the hunter who took it.
The Mothman that appeared with glowing red
eyes to warn of impending tragedy.
Most of all, she warned him about the deer.
"Sometimes," she used to say, "when you're
out in the woods late at night, you'll see
a deer acting a little bit funny.
Maybe it's making strange sounds.
Maybe it's standing up like a man.
Maybe it's staring at you from the shadows
and won't look away.
If you ever see one of these deer, promise
me you'll get away from it as fast as possible.
Don't look at it, don't talk to it, just get
far, far away."
He promised her every time.
But, as he got older, he started to forget
his grandma's stories, letting them fade away
with memories of the Easter Bunny and Santa
Claus.
He didn't think about the stories again until
he was older, a junior in college, and embarking
on a camping trip with his roommate, Josh.
They were both staying with Zane's family
for the summer, and had been enjoying the
sunshine and fresh air.
They'd gone hiking, picked blackberries, and
gone fishing to their hearts' content.
After a while, they got sick of sleeping in
the cramped house and decided to have a proper
camping trip out in the mountains.
Campsites were crowded this time of year,
but Zane knew a spot just isolated enough
that they could kick back, enjoy nature, and
relax in peace.
They packed their supplies and headed out
into the forest for a weekend they would never
forget.
By nightfall, Zane and Josh had pitched their
tents, built a fire, and were starting to
make some dinner.
They roasted hot dogs and heated cans of beans
over the fire, and decided to start telling
some classic scary stories.
Sitting by the crackling fire, listening to
the rustling leaves, snapping twigs, and the
chittering of animals all around, Zane couldn't
help but remember the stories he had almost
forgotten.
All of the strange, inexplicable things that
came out after the sun went down and the forest
went quiet.
He thought he could hear the footsteps of
something walking by their campsite, circling
them.
But it was probably just his imagination.
As Josh told stories about babysitters stalked
by killers and drivers picking up ghostly
hitchhikers, Zane was thinking about the deer.
He shuddered but shook it off, and after some
more stories and a few too many s'mores, the
two friends decided to get some sleep.
After several hours, Zane woke to the sound
of Josh unzipping his tent.
He sat up, ready to yell at his friend for
waking him up, but the sight of Josh's pale,
frightened face stopped him.
"There's something here..." was all Josh could
say.
His hands, Zane noticed, were shaking.
"Hey man, it's okay.
Let's check it out," Zane patted Josh on the
shoulder.
He was pretty sure his friend just wasn't
used to camping in actual nature, but reached
for his hunting knife just in case.
He grabbed a flashlight, and switched it on,
following Josh out into the darkness.
He swept the beam across the clearing, and
it illuminated a pair of orange eyes staring
directly at him from behind a nearby tree.
"What the..." he approached the shape, trying
to get a clear look at it.
As it became more illuminated, his stomach
dropped.
It was a deer, but something was...wrong with
it.
Its mouth was wide open, its jaw working up
and down like it was trying to make a sound,
but nothing came out.
But that wasn't the worst part.
As the flashlight beam illuminated the animal's
body, Zane realized that, somehow, its head
was on backwards.
"What the-" Josh appeared behind him, gasping.
"Shh!"
Zane shushed him intensely.
He suddenly remembered his grandmother's warnings.
"You know what?
I don't feel so great.
I think we should go back to the car and head
to my place."
He gave Josh a look, shaking his head as if
to say "don't say another word."
By the glow of their flashlights, the two
packed up their campsite, all under the gaze
of the misshapen deer.
They drove home in silence, Josh only speaking
once to ask: "What was that thing?"
Zane shook his head.
"I don't know.
But it wasn't a deer."
They crept back into the house, and went to
bed.
They knew they would never speak of tonight
ever again.
As Zane began to drift off to sleep, his last
conscious thought was to glance out the window.
There, in the yard not five feet away, was
a deer.
Watching.
He didn't know it, but that night Zane encountered
an instance of SCP-6448.
SCP-6448 is an anomalous species of creatures
that appear to belong to the Cervidae family,
nicknamed the "Not Deer."
They are highly intelligent and can be distinguished
from ordinary deer by unusual behavior and
physical deformities.
Some of these have included: legs that bend
backwards, the eyes of animals other than
deer, forward-facing eyes, jerky movements,
lack of fear toward humans, and walking on
two hind legs.
Most notably, and most frightening, SCP-6448
instances will watch and stalk humans, for
a duration of hours or even days.
They will follow humans home, and steal items
from their domains including weapons, food,
and other personal items.
They are most frequently found in the deep
woods at night, when a person is completely
alone.
If someone encounters an instance of SCP-6448,
if they acknowledge any of the creature's
anomalous traits, it will attack.
In order to limit the loss of life and ensure
that SCP Foundation employees exercise the
utmost caution when dealing with SCP-6448,
the Cryptozoology Division issued the following
guidelines:
"If you notice a deer that seems “off”,
look away and ignore it.
If it knows that you’ve noticed it, it’s
too late.
If you hear your name, whistling, or something
else in the woods calling for you, don’t
acknowledge it.
Never acknowledge it exists, don’t respond,
don’t go looking for it, don’t call back
to it.
If you’re walking at night and you feel
something breathing on your neck or whispering
behind you, the key to your safety is pretending
that everything is normal.
Your survival is dependant on your ignorance."
Whatever SCP-6448 is, they appear to be intelligent
enough to understand when they are being studied,
and they don't seem to like it very much.
On January 11, 1994, a group of three SCP-6448
instances broke into Site-41 in North Carolina,
using a tunnel they had carved over a long
period of time.
At that time, there was an instance in containment,
but in all of the chaos of the breach, the
specimen was lost.
Every time an instance was captured and contained
near SCP-6448's habitat, it would later escape
via similar tunnels.
SCP-6448 was officially classified by the
SCP Foundation in 1980, but those from the
Appalachian region have known about these
strange creatures since at least 1947.
From folktales and campfire stories to secondhand
and even firsthand encounters, the locals
are well aware of the Not Deer's existence,
and are largely familiar with the precautions
necessary to avoid them.
Though many of the civilians that encounter
SCP-6448 avoid notifying the authorities,
there have been several recorded 911 calls
involving the Not Deer since 2000.
The following is a log of those calls:
February 1, 2000:
"Victim (aged 41, female) dialed emergency
services after hearing their name being called
from the woods near their home.
The victim recounts the vocalization being
likened to a scream in a voice that they do
not recognize and requested assistance in
locating the source.
Emergency personnel requested the subject
place their phone on the floor outside the
home to listen for the alleged sounds.
After 2 minutes, a vocalization was heard
that was calling to the subject by name, emanating
from the nearby forest.
The subject was instructed to investigate
the disturbance themselves and keep services
updated on the situation.
The victim then begins to walk into the woodland,
getting about 50 meters into the underbrush
before inexplicably stopping.
They claim there to be a noticeably large
deer standing in the way of the path.
She begins to walk closer, though states it
does not move.
Subject diverts from the path and begins walking
in a different direction.
After 30 minutes, no source of the voice is
determined.
The caller returns to their residence."
June 13, 2002:
"Victim (aged 28, male) calls 911 regarding
a home break-in.
The caller notes numerous items to be missing
from their residence and requests an investigation.
Operators dispatch two investigators to visit
the home and pertain a potential perpetrator.
The pair note that, based on earlier CCTV
images, all cutlery, sharp objects, firearms,
lightbulbs, and a single copy of the novel
‘The Day After Roswell’ are missing.
Also noted is that there is a complete lack
of any fingerprints at the scene, with no
doors or windows having been broken into.
Analysis of the home’s CCTV footage revealed
there to be a two hour period of missing film,
with the exception of a single frame containing
a Cervus nippon on its hind legs, reaching
towards the camera.
Its frontal hooves have been warped to resemble
fingers.
No footage of the entity exiting the home
was discovered."
November 19, 2005:
"A cattle farmer (aged 54, male) reported
to local authorities the sudden disappearance
of over 30% of his largest herd.
Response teams searched the nearby area for
4 hours though found no trace of the cattle.
The victim was recommended to set up trail
cameras and note any unusual activity overnight.
At 01:11 AM, two SCP-6448 are seen walking
through the field before fleeing.
One places an object into the ground, later
discovered to be a single fork.
A week after this discovery, 200 discarded
bovine hooves appear at the location."
March 4, 2009:
"Victim (age unknown, gender unknown) dials
911 to request assistance from animal services.
The victim is standing within a forest in
front of a Cervus elaphus, which is violently
contorting.
The victim attempts to state "You better get
a vet or something, I don't think it's well"
before a piercing screech is heard and the
line falls silent.
Recovered footage depicts the aforementioned
animal squirming, seemingly in pain.
A viscous churning is audible as a black mass
erupts out of the instance, and the video
turns to static."
October 11, 2012:
"Victim (aged 23, male) is a junior wildlife
officer at Cherokee National Forest, Tennessee.
They radio their supervisor in the early evening
regarding a herd of Odocoileus virginianus
within the reserve.
Supposedly, there is a single animal that,
upon first glance, appears average, though
possesses divergent attributes, including
backwards joints, enlarged abdomen, and forward-facing
eyes.
Upon stating this, a distant whistle is audible,
and the victim stumbles slightly.
They begin to say “What the he- did it just
whistle at me?”
before the sound of hooves rapidly getting
closer is heard.
Notably, the hoof steps did not sound to be
in the traditional gallop of a cervid."
October 12, 2012:
"The former victim’s supervisor calls authorities
following the victim’s absence from the
reserve night shift.
Following this, their radio begins to crackle.
The victim’s voice can be heard on the other
end, and he requests the supervisor’s attention.
He calls regarding a herd of Odocoileus
virginianus within the reserve.
They claim there is a single animal that upon
first glance appears average, though possesses
divergent attributes including backwards joints,
enlarged abdomen and forward facing eyes.
Suspecting the creature to be a rare genetic
malformation, the victim requests their supervisor
to come to the location.
The supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous.
There is no reply.
Upon the supervisor’s and law enforcement’s
arrival at the site, a herd of approximately
80 Odocoileus virginianus was present.
A single entity is in the field’s center
and appears to be standing separate from the
rest of the group.
It flees the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement’s presence.
Where it formerly stood laid a standard two-way
radio."
April 8, 2016:
“Victim (aged 35, female) dials 911 using
a satellite phone, distressed.
They state that they are in [REDACTED] County
Woods and are being followed.
She claims that, despite seeing no one for
the duration of her hike, she “feels as
if she’s being watched” and has heard
someone walking behind her at various points
in the trip.
The victim is unable to give an adequate description
of their location, but knows the route to
return to her residence.
Operators request the victim to return to
a point wherein she can provide a sufficient
geographic description of her position.
The victim remains on the line for the
duration of the hike back to a readily used
portion of the wilderness trail.
Along the journey, various unnatural sounds
can be heard.
These include footsteps, rockslides, coughing,
whispering, and whistling.
Nearing the main trail, all woodland noises,
such as birds and wind, cease suddenly, and
the victim states she can see a malformed
deer carcass coated in a thick layer of black
slime.
At this time, human screams can be heard in
the distance.
Operators request the victim continue and
ignore other stimuli.
Agents embedded in local law enforcement,
suspecting SCP-6448 involvement, notify Gamma-4
to the situation.
20 minutes later, the victim returns to the
main trail.
Gamma-4, now operating the 911 call, informs
the victim not to respond to any further unusual
activity and briefly outlines Cervus Protocol.
For the duration of the victim’s journey
to her home, two sets of breathing are audible.
The victim successfully returns to her residence
and shuts the door behind her.
Now out of sight from SCP-6448, agents inquire
at the victim’s address, and the victim
promptly complies.
Operatives instruct the victim to have possession
of all firearms and weapons on the premises
and to barricade herself inside a safe space
with one exit point.
The victim swiftly begins grabbing all available
weapons and throwing them inside a wardrobe.
It is at this time that there is a knock on
the front door.
The victim does not respond and continues
to hoard sharp objects from kitchen drawers.
The knocking becomes more violent as the handle
is jostled and shaken incessantly.
A voice on the other side repeats the phrase
“Hello, it is me.
Hello, let me in.”
in a calm manner as the door begins to shake.
The victim retreats to her wardrobe, armed
with a small firearm.
Upon sealing herself in the space, the knocking
ceases, and footsteps can be heard becoming
further away.
The sound of galloping is audible as the front
door caves in.
Hoof steps can now be heard inside the home.
The entity continues to repeat “Hello, it
is me.
Hello, let me in.”
as it searches the small building.
A bright light flashes overhead, seemingly
circling the house.
Eventually, the entity enters the victim’s
bedroom.
Through a small slit in the wardrobe door,
the victim can see a Cervus canadensis standing
on its hind legs and surveying the room.
Its movements are crooked and stiff, seeming
to struggle to stand in a bipedal fashion.
It slouches down to a quadrupedal crouch,
similar to the stance of an arachnid.
It inhales heavily, and its head locks on
the view of the wardrobe.
It is noted as possessing human eyes.
It scampers towards the subject and opens
the door.
A single gunshot is heard.
Responders found no trace of either SCP-6448
or the victim."
Containment of SCP-6448 is focused on the
investigation of any deer exhibiting anomalous
traits in and around the Appalachian area.
Any civilian sightings of SCP-6888 are to
be handled by Mobile Task Force Gamma-4, or
the "Green Stags".
Any possible deaths resulting from SCP-6448
will be blamed on hiking accidents, and any
reported sightings can be explained away with
Chronic Wasting Disease.
CWD, occasionally referred to as "zombie deer
disease" is a prion disease affecting members
of the Cervidae family.
Symptoms of the illness include loss of motor
function control and damage to decision making,
as well as gradual degradation of all mental
faculties.
It is one hundred percent fatal.
However, though the disease does exist, most
recorded cases of it in the Appalachian region
can actually be attributed to instances of
SCP-6448.
Any captured instances of SCP-6448 should
be transported to Site-44 for the Cryptozoology
Division's containment and study.
On November 29, 2019, they finally got their
chance to bring a Not Deer into custody.
The Green Stags were able to capture an instance
of SCP-6448 with help from MTF Nu-7, "Hammer
Down", and their heavy vehicles division,
as well as some experimental shock rifles.
One Not Deer was knocked unconscious in the
conflict, and its body was loaded onto an
armored helicopter and flown straight to Site-44
in Essex, England.
At the site, it was then placed in a reinforced
steel containment cell, and heavily sedated.
This entire process went off without a hitch.
As the entity began to regain consciousness,
Cryptozoology Specialist F. Ozz watched it
through a one-way glass window and attempted
to speak to it through the intercom.
"Greetings, SCP-6448," Researcher Ozz began.
At the sound of his voice, the creature jumped
to its feet, staring at the intercom.
"Can you understand me?
We've seen your genus speak English just fine
in the past."
The animal did not answer, but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it were
an ordinary deer.
Researcher Ozz sighed impatiently.
"Please, we know your secret."
The Not Deer stopped what it was doing, freezing
completely still as it listened to his words.
"Admittedly, it wasn't exactly well kept.
If you'd just look at yourself for more than
a few seconds, it is very clear that you're
not...normal."
At this, the creature, which had been facing
away from the window, swiveled its neck 180
degrees, breaking its own spine with an audible
crack.
It stared, unblinking, at the window and directly
at Researcher Ozz.
Ozz turned to the containment staff, suddenly
anxious.
"I thought you said this was one-way?"
The staff assured him that it was, and there
was no way the Not Deer could see him.
Still, its eyes were locked directly on his
face.
He shook off the sense of unease and continued
his line of questioning.
"Are you something imitating deer?
It is clear that, if so, you possess basic
anatomical knowledge of them, though details
are clearly faulty.
In fact, a better question would be...how?
If, in fact, you are not what you pretend
to be."
The Not Deer opened its mouth at this, revealing
unusually sharp teeth.
It moved its jaw as if attempting to speak,
but only a choking sound came out.
"Shall we move on?"
Ozz asked.
"What I'm more concerned with here is why
you take our people.
Is it a vendetta?
Spite?
Food?"
For the first time in the interview, the Not
Deer blinked.
It was an unnatural movement, forced and deliberate,
like the creature was attempting to engage
in an ordinary behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse.
"Responding is mandatory," Researcher Ozz
prompted.
The creature did not react.
"If you will not comply," Ozz's tone grew
stern, frustrated.
"Maybe you'd like to see your brand new containment
cell."
At last, the entity spoke.
"R-Rasaerch.
Research."
Its voice resembled a distorted version of
Ozz's.
"Research?
What kind of..."
Ozz wasn't able to finish his question.
"July 7, 1947," the creature said, before
ramming into the one-way glass and cracking
it.
As Ozz stumbled backward from the force, the
creature collapsed on the ground, seizing
and screaming as its abdomen.
"Get the Stags in here now!"
Ozz cried out, but it was too late.
A black mass of something shiny and tendriled
leaped out of the Not Deer, scuttling around
the cell before shattering the window and
leaving the empty shell of a deer behind.
The Site-44 Breach System activated and attempted
to initiate emergency containment protocols,
but the mysterious black mass escaped its
sector, made its way toward the main exit,
broke through the glass on the front exit
door, and vanished into the shrubbery outside.
The escaped anomaly could not be found and
recontained.
Ever since this incident, there have been
a record-breaking number of Chronic Wasting
Disease cases identified in deer in the surrounding
area, as well as an unprecedented increase
in UFO reports.
Further research is currently ongoing, but
it is unknown whether we will ever truly know
what these creatures are.
Only one thing is for certain: they are definitely
not deer.
Now go check out “SCP-966 - Sleep Killer”
and “SCP-2571 - Cragglewood Park” for
more anomalies that’ll ensure you’ll never
want to sleep again!
Wait, is that a deer behind you?
Oh, god--